when you guys went to see Trump you guys
went on Air Force One right we did yeah
and so what was that
it was pretty cool I mean especially
since I'm Canadian I don't know how many
Canadians have been on there right yeah
it's kind of cool I don't know
um but it was cool I I said before I
personally felt like the interior is
like a little outdated right like I feel
like they could get an interior designer
in there and [__] it's big and [__] it's
massive
but I feel like the interior designer
maybe should be fired or something or
does it look just more fan does it look
like it's kind of boring like your dad's
office yeah yeah your dad's office type
Vibes and [__] fault but it was it's it
was really cool like we were supposed to
interview Trump that time this was right
before the election too wow like right
before and then um so people were hating
him then was it the first election yes
so people were hating him the second
election first election oh first
election oh no sorry second yeah yeah
that's when people were really really
hating them yeah yeah exactly so because
at first he kind of represented this
Underdog type of thing you know
um well you think when he ran against
Clinton people didn't hate him as much I
think people hated him more the second
time second time but the media also
always hated him right you know I think
that he would have who somebody else
would have done a little bit better in
his position if they'd had a little I
don't know if he was the best speaker
but then also I don't know why we need
the who Trump's not the best speaker I
mean he's great but I don't know if he's
it connects to people that well he's a
good speaker I just think he has a
little too much like baggage
yeah totally for the average person
right like
yeah but when he made it that far I
remember when he got elected I was like
holy [__] dude
any of us could be president crazy right
like [__] I know no one thought he
was going to win the first time I I was
shocked oh when he first came out in the
beginning I was like I think he's gonna
win because yeah look like we went with
Dana and then we were supposed to
interview him right so we thought we
were going to interview him and then the
last second they came in they're like yo
we're not doing it and we're like [__]
they're like yeah like Trump wants you
guys to come into his office though and
like he wants to meet you guys and [__]
we're like and they're like you could
film it so like all right so we go in
and like Trump's watching [__] like
Ted Cruz on the TV and he's like
chirping them like making fun of him and
[__] and then they bring Trump on the TV
and he's like look guys look look how
skinny I look there look how skinny I
look I was just like no way he's exactly
like TV in real life and then he's just
like oh look at like look at these
handsome guys like such handsome guy
like complimenting us yeah
it was pretty crazy and then we went to
his rally uh-huh and he pulled us up on
stage for the [__] YMCA the outro
like you know his way his getaway song
yeah he pulled us up on stage and we
ripped the YMCA with Trump and then he
he feed posted it on his Instagram
and we were [__] hyped bro bro he's
never been to a YMCA in his life I know
he loves it he says it's the gay
national anthem right oh yeah but it's
just crazy that he's never but there's
no way that he's been to a YMCA I know
but when he posted that on his Instagram
we were like holy [__] bro you're like
we're shocked yeah it's like what the
[__] just happened we're in another Air
Force One YMCA with Trump to like I
can't believe this [__]
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one